[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings almost all
of the electronics we use rely on
microchips the demand for them jumped
during the pandemic and production
disruptions and supply chain issues made
it difficult for suppliers to keep up
chip shortages cost the economy billions
that's right billions in 2021. now
experts want the government to step in
and help american manufacturers make
more chips meg oliver is in malta new
york 20 miles north of albany inside one
of the factories at the forefront of
chip production in the u.s meg that's a
serious suit and a serious operation
over there isn't it posing
you need a little attitude to wear this
nate i gotta tell you good morning no
one is allowed in here unless you're
dressed like me from head to toe that's
because we're in the clean room where
they like to boast it's a thousand times
more sanitary than an operating room
they produce about a million microchips
daily but the need is so great i need to
put out at least 10 times more than that
how big is this facility so this
facility is about 420 000 square feet
and that's a
give or take about seven football fields
here at global foundries in upstate new
york everything looks yellow special
lighting is used to protect the delicate
production of microchips engineer
christopher belfy is equipment manager
how complex is it to make these
microchips they're in everything we use
phones tvs cars
it is extremely complex and as the
demand on capability increases so does
the complexity chips are needed for just
about all devices laptops home
appliances like refrigerators gaming
consoles and medical equipment the chips
are the brains of devices the u.s
produces just around 12 percent of the
world's supply and we've relied heavily
on ships produced in asia but when the
pandemic hit it shut down major
production plans decreasing supply we
don't want to rely on foreign entities
to be able to give us the brains and the
guts of what drive our everyday
vehicles devices our cell phones there
is renewed focus on producing more chips
at home as some experts warn not doing
so could also be a national security
risk the house is currently considering
the chips for america act that would
provide u.s manufacturers with 52
billion dollars in funding to help boost
domestic production why is it so
important to manufacture on american
soil well i think it starts first and
foremost
with security it's kind of trusted
supply chain
the second is just think about the
economic activity a manufacturing
facility brings to the u.s we employ
over 3000 employees at this site tom
caulfield is the ceo of global foundries
in addition to upstate new york they
have facilities in vermont germany and
singapore what stage are we at in this
chip shortage i'd like to be more
optimistic and tell you that right
around the corner helps on its way
just the complexity of technology that
it takes years to put capacity on and i
think
for the better part of the next five to
ten years
we'll be chasing supply in this industry
not demand experts estimate the chip
shortage cost the u.s economy around 240
billion dollars last year a recent
report from the department of commerce
found in 2021 demand for chips were as
high as 17 percent more than in 2019.
this is what everybody wants this is the
gold caulfield says they'll continue to
try to meet demand but they need private
investments and federal funding through
the chips bill it's really important
that we have supply chain security in
the u.s and know and sleep well at night
that gf will do their part
when the chips bill is funded
both the house and senate have passed
their own versions of the chips act and
while there appears to be
bipartisan agreement there is not an
official agreement just yet so no
funding tony
yeah people want that supply chain to be
secure we used to make a lot of chips
good to see that we are ramping up
production once again meg oliver in the
suit in malta new york thank you very
much